they were just going to go with what
streaming services have been doing the
last few years and just throwing money
at the series but now they've had a bit
of a rethink and it looks like they've
decided to go with a pilot instead Sam
esmail the showrunner has been talking
about how they are nearly ready to go to
Pilot and he says it'll probably be
quite soon again talk to my sources I
can tell you that by quite soon he means
the new year and really currently
they're just looking at finalizing the
script and that they are hoping that
basically by March they'll be looking
for a studio and actually doing those
practical things of getting ready to
shoot a lot of casting apparently is
already in a preliminary stage and
they're really hoping to get going
within 3 or 4 months and